you've done this stay-at-home PSA oh
yeah you can love it where you advise
people to stay home and I just want to
put up this picture of you after you've
done your own makeup
what's with this it is really fantastic
how's that look going over for you um
well my phone stopped ringing if that's
your question do you think you will work
again that's my question
done between that look and the like 35
extra pounds I've gained it's finished
wait you you got you've got a pretty
nice shout out online about your new
look yes I did did you see who shouted
out at me I did Christmas Day it
Captain America baby alright you wanted
me to say it cuz you didn't want to brag
and then you said Captain America baby
yeah he is he's one of the best looking
men in the world and he's his new
celebrity crush yes that was so nice and
did you see what I tweeted back to him
because you see really the point of the
PSA was to tell people to stay the hell
home and stay six feet apart if you have
to go out and and so I said Avengers
Assemble six feet apart big speed up yes
that's great
that's great assemble while social
distancing correct you know and it's
funny because everybody's saying
practice social distancing which I think
that that verb is is a misleading I
don't think they should practice it they
should do it
you know cuz practice suggests a
looseness about this and there is no
looseness here right now you take this
distancing thing very seriously what
happens when you encounter someone who's
not taking it seriously
well honestly I it's happened to me now
once where I confronted somebody from
afar I have a sort of a road rage about
this and I think it's justified if you
don't mind my saying
that in my defense I was in CVS I had to
go I had to pick up some prescriptions
and this woman walks by me this close
like she's like 18 inches from my body
so already I'm in a having a complete
[ __ ] fit and then I look at I'm so
alarmed and then I look at her no mask
no gloves and I said hey don't walk
close to people and you should be
wearing a mask and gloves I say to her
and she looked at me like this I mean
she was so uh i frightened her I didn't
mean to frighten her but I I had to let
her know that this is no bueno and I'm
not really somebody who does something
like that a lot but this time I really
had to and I'm gonna continue to do it
did she know it was you
no cuz I had on a mask I had on gloves
I'm like 78 pounds heavier
so I'm unrecognizable furthermore I've
got this I've put shoe polish in my hair
right now but I've got like that much
gray grow out uh-huh
so I look like a witch is what I'm
saying it looked like a wish I had this
gray I had this massive ass I've got a
mask like here and you know I mean it
was all bad III I guess I must have
frightened her with my look maybe I'm
nothing to do with what I was saying and
so so now I do you say you look like a
witch you're acting kind of like a witch
you're you're shouting at people get
away exactly